- What would you like
a freestyle rap about?
- [Audience Member] Labia majora.
- Labia majora, thank you very much.
The larger of the labia.
Mate, you didn't realize there's
actually four labia, right?
(audience laughing)
There's the, the big old elephant ears,
and then there's the kind of like,
you know, sides of a stingray.
(audience laughing)
Just a little bit inside.
Labia majora. My favorite of the labia.
The ones you can see more, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Who doesn't love a big
old puffy pair of lips?
(audience laughs)
It's nice.
Love them. Love them.
Especially.. Oh, oh yeah, right?
What? Labia majora. Cool.
This side, this here, this, this triangle.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Bad Bunny
- What did you say?
- [Audience Member] Bad Bunny.
- Bad Bunny.
Are you you Puerto Rican?
Yeah. Are you very, Are you
just watching me being like,
nah, you're not gonna
rap as well as Bad Bunny.
(audience laughing)
Cool. Bad Bunny.
I may take, as someone who listens to rap,
but not really to Bad Bunny.
And that's no disrespect to him.
I'm sure he's very, very good.
I just find it very
boring to have every beat
that I hear just go (beatboxing)
like does every song
need to have that beat?
It doesn't, but Bad Bunny
will be the suggestion.
I might take it in different avenues.
Bad Bunny, labia majora.
Gosh, you're all so quiet and respectful.
This is the only time in a hip hop show
that everyone's just gone
we will be as quiet as we possibly can.
(audience laughing)
So it's like when Kanye
raps, and everyone listens,
going, yeah, but we paid $120, mate, so,
do a song.
Middle of the room.
So far, labia majora, Bad Bunny.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Bubble tea.
- I beg your pardon?
- Bubble tea. Lovely stuff.
You were saying bubble
team and not boba tea,
'cause I learned that, that in Taiwan,
they laugh at us, in the west,
for calling it boba tea, 'cause
boba means massive boobs.
(audience laughing)
- in Taiwan,
and so they think we're very silly.
Bubble tea. Lovely. Love it.
Bubble tea. Corner of the room over there.
And don't worry this time
I'm coming to you last.
Bubble tea, Bad Bunny, the labia majora.
What do you guys want a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Marijuana farming.
- Marijuana farming. Thank you.
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
Are you yourself a marijuana farmer?
- [Audience Member] No!
- No? Why did you just go 'No'?
What's wrong with that? That
sounds like an amazing job.
- [Audience Member] It does sound nice.
- What is your job?
- [Audience Member] Advertising.
- An advertiser. Do you work
in advertising of marijuana?
- [Audience Member] No.
- No, Okay. You're not gonna
say your advertising firm,
'cause you don't wanna be
connected with marijuana,
'cause, you know, it's
a deviant hippy drug.
(audience laughing)
Marijuana farming,
boba tea, labia majora, Bad Bunny.
Final enclave. What would
you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Deep sea animals.
- [Audience Member 2] Oh, no animals.
- Yeah. So wait, what was
the first word you said?
- [Audience Member] Deep.
- Deep. Oh, where's your accent from?
- [Audience Member] Australia.
- Yeah. Cool.
(audience laughing)
He didn't say deep sea animals,
he said dape say animals.
(audience laughing)
So, deep sea animals.
I'm gonna go with deep sea creatures,
it's more phonetically pleasing.
Deep sea creatures, marijuana farming.
There's some beautiful
assonance in that, well done.
We've got labia majora,
we've got Bad Bunny.
And what was our middle
of the room one again?
- [Audience Member] Bubble tea.
- Bubble tea. Of course.
How can we forget that?
Well, this is what we're gonna do.
We're gonna do a freestyle
rap about all that shit.
And that's a rap made up on the spot,
based entirely on your suggestions.
Not written, not prepared, not rehearsed.
And I would like you to know
that it's not gonna be anywhere near
as atrociously shit
as you're expecting it to be.
(audience laughing)
'Cause you're all so patiently waiting
for this to absolutely bomb.
But it's, it's gonna be amazing.
♪ My rap will make you feel whole ♪
♪ It will complete you in the
high pressure environment ♪
♪ Those creatures at
the bottom of the sea. ♪
♪ You'll get your wish ♪
♪ Australian boy saying
rap about an angler fish ♪
♪ That's the one with the
tiny light on the prong ♪
♪ walking over there, deep sea ♪
♪ no pond, no tiny little river ♪
♪ I feel a little quiver ♪
♪ when I see the sea anemone ♪
♪ start to slither ♪
♪ A sea cucumber ♪
♪ Oh, I wish I went ♪
♪ snorkeling down there,
Great Barrier reef, then ♪
♪ It be shooting out all
of the life I can see ♪
♪ Fills me with glee, now come with me ♪
♪ I'll be asking you to
sip upon bubble tea. ♪
♪ Maybe over there far east Taiwanese ♪
♪ If you want to get a good
drink, can you go there ♪
♪ Basically caffeine with the tapioca ♪
♪ Tiny little spheres,
the milk not clear ♪
♪ It's kind of opaque,
translucent in here ♪
♪ You've gotta make sure
you get a large straw ♪
♪ Otherwise it sucks ♪
♪ and you can't get more ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ It be stuck there in the tube. ♪
♪ I'll be like bubble tea, what
problem's wrong with you? ♪
♪ I need to suck suck ♪
♪ It gets to my throat ♪
♪ The problem, too many spheres ♪
♪ and I choke, start to block my belly ♪
♪ My Adam's apple swells ♪
♪ I say, oh, I worry it won't end well ♪
♪ I try and reach back to
my tonsils and grab it ♪
♪ And then I pull it out ♪
♪ And I see a bunny rabbit over there ♪
♪ He says, I ain't being funny ♪
♪ I like to chew carrots, fuck bitches ♪
♪ I'm a bunny ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Whoa. Yeah. ♪
♪ It's kind of sad that I see a bunny ♪
♪ He'll be like, I'm bad ♪
♪ What do you mean no joking in the lab ♪
♪ I'm smoking every day ♪
♪ Get to marijuana I'm toking ♪
♪ The Bad Bunny, he's a great rap star ♪
♪ But I know none of his songs ♪
♪ So this is where we are ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ I take the little bunny,
he's a real charmer ♪
♪ Hopping in the field,
spies a marijuana farmer ♪
♪ The guy walks in, he's
like our best boast ♪
♪ All the bunnies over here,
check it on the west coast ♪
♪ I'll be growing, showing ♪
♪ All my Mary Jane, get
the sun coming down ♪
♪ UV with the flame, maybe grow inside ♪
♪ You know that I'm on it,
get my big green leaves ♪
♪ Female, hydroponic,
if you get the males ♪
♪ It will cut down your
size of your yield ♪
♪ Why, 'cause the flowers fertilize ♪
♪ And then it doesn't make the
buds, you can't get sticky ♪
♪ Advertiser over there ♪
♪ are you with me ♪
(audience whooping)
♪ You're having such trouble ♪
♪ I know I might bore ya ♪
♪ Let me blow it up
like the labia majora ♪
(audience whooping)
♪ It's heaven sent, so pleasant ♪
♪ With the ears looking like an elephant ♪
♪ Indian or African,
doesn't matter the size ♪
♪ I spy it, fix my eyes
between the sides ♪
♪ I see the, those labia
majora with the urgency ♪
♪ And let me say this,
there's no need for surgery ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ If they're puffy, if they're bloated ♪
♪ I'm still like, yes, I'll
give it full throated ♪
♪ Give the lady hey ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ I'm sucking like a leaf ♪
♪ And like it gets stuck in
my throat, like boba tea ♪
(audience clapping and whooping)